the raft is secure but I can't reach
them over radio their comms must be down
and what's your status already here
URI I thought you said it was secure it
was let's go
maybe it's not as bad as it looks love
the optimism but in my experience when
it looks bad it's usually worse look out
[Music]
hold on
you okay yeah welcome to the park just
in time for the fireworks looks like we
made parole boy electro why is he
letting everyone out I'll head for the
main control center and see how bad the
situation got it I'll go join the party
everyone just quietly go back into your
cells and lock the door behind you
[Music]
like fishing a beer that doesn't sound
good
oh hi RINO hope you like surprise spider
surprise what is he talking about
hey watch me just trapped in a prison
with every criminal I put away in the
last eight years no biggie
electrum must be working for someone
this is too good to be true
scorpion can you hold on a minute I was
in the middle of a phone call and it was
business
don't let up lost you for a second there
you okay
not really electro rhino and now
scorpion are all on the loose what's
going on in the rest of the prison
camera system sometimes I'll give you a
sitrep soon okay I'll keep tracking
electro come on spider-man I thought
this was a shake Gus stop this guy
[Music]
if you tell me who you're working for
I'll go easy on you can't stop it
what up planet that you still try nobody
ever takes me up on that offer butcher
long time no see we're gonna have so
much sorry no time to talk
okay I got the security cameras back
online how's it look
well it looks like the entire population
of the rap game
that makes the vibe of your worst
enemies that are now on the loose for a
second there I thought you were serious
I am serious I'd have to go some of them
are heading into the city this is not
keep chasing parties almost dark
a lot wrong stop
how do you like my new suit
dashing where'd you get it it's an
exclusive club
[Music]
remember he said not to kill him
good idea in fact we don't have to do
this at all if you don't want to we
definitely want
you
hey everybody its Charlie so we finally
got more spider-man ps4 footage it was
Sony's press conference at e3 so there
was obviously a whole bunch of other
games if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos they'll be giveaway stuff that
I'll explain at the end of the video but
the whole idea is that in this universe
it's an older version of Peter Parker
the kingpin has been sort of controlling
the city but he gets put behind bars so
he jokes to Peter Parker that he kept a
certain amount of order in the city so
even though the kingpin is a spider-man
villain he had a way of keeping the city
working from completely eating itself
alive when he gets thrown in prison it
leaves a power vacuum for another
villain to rise that villain is mr.
negative you've seen him in a couple of
the other trailers before Martin Lee is
sort of his other aspect a friend of
Peter Parker's so that's why when this
sort of new version of the sinister six
is beating the crap out of him on top of
the raft here and you see this white
light flash and it says oh my gosh it's
you the whole thing about that is that
it's probably one of his friends because
one of mr. negatives abilities is
manipulating the dark force and bringing
out the evil in people so he can change
people's alignment so he could turn what
a Peter Parker's friends into a villain
that's probably why he's staring into
this white light at the end of the
trailer going oh my god it's you like he
couldn't believe that somebody would
turn on him so we just get to see some
of the gameplay mechanics some of his
midair combos it's spider-man so
obviously he's gonna have a bunch of
midair combos but you have upgraded
versions of electro rhino scorpion
vulture mr. negative hasn't been a
really big character in the movies so
far I love the way that Yuri says that
five of your most dangerous villains
have escaped the raft and he jokes ah
haha you know why don't we make it one
more and we'll make it an even sinister
six so the whole idea of this over
narrative is that you have this giant
raft prison break so all the most
dangerous spider-man and Marvel villains
escape in in New York City spider-man
has to take them down but the big
villain to be taken down is mr. negative
but the thing is is that his friend the
other aspect of mr. negative is Martin
Lee that he's trying to save so it's not
one of those situations where you could
just kill the villain and solve all your
problems
Plus pending instant kill mode
spider-man isn't really hot on killing
people so just let me know what you
think of the footage so far but
obviously this is going to be coming out
in Sept
so there's gonna be a whole bunch of
comic-book stuff happening then we'll
learn a little bit more about the other
stuff that's gonna be dropping you know
comic book related at Comic Con this
summer but it looks really badass and
obviously it's like a really big arkham
style open-world game so there's butch a
side quest they'll be dlc i'm sure so
there's a whole bunch of stuff that we
haven't seen yet in the latest big
costume bonus that they just released
was the iron spider costume after
infinity war so there'd be a bunch of
other costume reveals coming up - since
this game is coming out pretty soon i'll
do the giveaway for this game so
obviously all you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video but click here for
brand new infinity war and click here to
learn all about Jeff Jones doing the new
Green Lantern horror movie thank you so
much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]